now I don't know about any of you but
I've always wondered because Daniel
turned 25 two days ago
what 6,500 people singing happy birthday
might sound like does anyone wanna buy
now
definitely close people that have ever
said that to me thank you very much yeah
thanks guys
that's why I love thank you right yeah
Dan you have your pick of basically
anything you probably want to do when it
comes to film tell me why you wanted to
do this movie um well you know I mean it
all starts with the script obviously the
script was fantastic for this film and
I'm always looking for things that are
original and and dark and also things
that take an idea that we can kind of
all relate to not necessarily the idea
of being accused of murdering your ex
dopher Oh your girlfriend but the fact
that you know he is he's been cast out
he's been made to feel an outsider he's
dealing with loss and it's so there are
themes that kind of everyone can
recognize but it just deals with them in
such an insane wild exciting way and you
know I really like films that are you
know that sort of defies genre and and
you know the I think there are some
directors that would have come to this
material and you know it's because the
book is it's it's very funny and witty
and also incredibly emotional and
romantic and has these horror and
fantasy elements to it as well obviously
that are key and I think some directors
might have gone to that and gone oh well
you know I'll just also take the easy
way out and just to make it funny or
just make it about the horror and you
know Alex fearless Lee and seamlessly
minutes all those all those different
tons and styles together and it's a you
know it's an unpredictable film and
that's what's exciting about it Joe it's
been a few years since the book came out
did you always envision or hope that it
would be a film and what was it like to
kind of go through this whole process
and now at the Eva it actually coming
out in theaters I don't think that I
ever really did expect it to be a film
because it's dark it's it's it's a
pretty it has it goes in a lot of dark
and upsetting places and I certainly
didn't didn't think that we you know
we'd be so lucky is to get someone like
Daniel Radcliffe to take on the part as
as it perished egg in the course of the
story experiences a lot he experiences
grief and rage madness and despair
delight and hope and that's a lot of
emotional terrain to cover and and I
thought that Dan brought all those all
those things to the park and made it
look easy
that he went to all those places
emotionally and it was effortless and I
always think whenever you see someone
bring that level of craft and and take
something that's hard and make it look
easy you're you're seeing someone who's
really pushed themselves very hard we
sort of dedicated themselves to their
craft in a very serious way so we got
tremendously lucky that and wanted to do
the film well thank you for letting me
do it yeah Alex from your point of view
is this something that you chased did
your team bring it to you and then also
were you and how involved were you with
the casting and was that your idea or
was the idea that was presented to you
to have them do it
I mean it was like I remember finishing
Purana and reading the book and I was
literally blown away by turning the
pages and going from as you describe it
so many like such a spectrum of like
different genre emotion tone you know I
was laughing and then I was emotional
and then I was like scared and I was
amazing and I uh I knew by the end of
the read that I had to make this movie
and I was lucky to you know like really
like step up and go and talk to you know
like Cathy Schumer and produce the movie
and and and have her let me develop the
movie and you were involved in the
writing of the script as well and then
you know down the road we the biggest
challenge to make all those general work
together in a very organic way in the
movie was to find the right egg parish
and I remember at the time that was like
something that we were discussing and I
think then if I remember well you came
to us you you read it and you were like
so obsessed with the character and Ida
Thomas before women in black so I
couldn't really you know know about you
walk
we met I was really impressed by the
conviction that you had and I knew that
you were and I was not expecting that we
are so skilled as an actor that you were
able to then you know just deliver on
every every different kind of emotion so
it was just a blessing to have you thank
you very much
one of the moments that we see in the
trailer is when egg first discovers
himself that morning with the beginnings
of the horns coming out of this warhead
that's a great reaction shot what was it
like for you as Dan the first time you
saw yourself in a mirror with the horns
on it's fantastic I mean I really I
really enjoyed I was kind of worried
about the you know the prosthetics in
this film just cuz you know prosthetics
can be a hard thing to to do and I mean
Mike fields and Mike McCarthy who did my
makeup on it would just I mean they're
artists and they didn't beautiful work
not just I mean the horns only took sort
of 20 minutes to put on by the end you
know they were very fast and even though
sort of a look at the end of the movie
which is much more extreme was only sort
of a couple of hours so they're I mean
they're just amazing and they made my
life so much easier but yeah there's
something incredibly empowering about
standing with a set of horns on or just
and really looking like the devil you
find that you know you kind of forget
you have them on and you start having
totally normal conversations with people
and then what happens is actually what
would happen in the film you sort of
just see people's eyes to drift up to
the horns gradually and kind of start to
fixate on them so no I thoroughly
enjoyed it and the cool thing about the
movie is you all see with you when you
see it is that when people encounter a
with these horns
it makes them just lose any filter and
expose themselves verbally and tell him
all the bad things that they've done or
that they want to do so which is part of
the fun of the movie which brings it to
the next question which is that it
really is a cool balance the book and
the film of scary elements funny
elements and a really moving love story
as well so Joe I'm curious to hear what
that was like to put all those elements
together when you were writing and then
Alex the same for you putting it all
together all three of those
now someone someone asked about the film
and and wanted to know you know is it a
tragedy is it a horror movie and I
thought about it for a second and then
said I think it's it tried to calm
Authority um you know it used to be
there was a time in the 70s when films
dared a lot and did a lot you know and I
think as time has gone on we've seen
things become more conservative and so
you'll go see a horror film which might
be great but would just be scary that's
all it does is scared or you'll see an
action film and the only thing you'll
see is buildings collapsing
and and I think that the human
experience is richer than just sort of
one emotional note and I always hope
that a book or film will will dare to
explore a little war and I also think
for horror to be effective for you to to
care about the characters that it's good
to see them in in comic moments in
tragic moments to see that they have a
rich inner emotional life otherwise I
think you know you don't you don't get
the same the same power the same
emotional impact you want to believe in
the humanity of the people on on the
screen and that means seeing more than
just a series of jump scares which would
you what's the hardest thing to do as a
filmmaker make someone scream make
someone laugh or make someone cry I
think is the dista position of
everything you know try to go from a
very suspenseful moment to a very funny
moment and create a surprise play with
the expectation of the audience try to
make the experience unexpected try to
just play with all the general against
each other within the story that's
completely [ __ ] on its own and and
following the the journey of a character
with Parrish but I was agreed
I think one thing we know is when when
we get really psyched about a film you
see a film it really charges you up you
know you get excited because you've seen
a series of scenes and every scene had a
little explosion of Awesome in it and
that explosion of awesome is always a
character moment it's never someone
punching someone it's never a dam
collapsing it's always something a
character said it's when you have a
character you love and then you see them
go in a direction you didn't expect and
explore something you didn't expect them
in to feel and you know I think when you
see the more successful and ambitious
genre films like cabin in the woods for
example you know you're seeing by the
way I can't it's just it's just so
amazing to be in Hall age you know this
is Joss Whedon's but swept ones erase
this chair I almost feel like that his
like thing his essence melting up into
me you know it's just it's awesome but
you know that's what you want to see is
ultimately when you see a film you love
it's because you loved those people it's
not because you loved a special effect
or you know fast editing or whatever and
hopefully and I think it does i think
that horns gives those moments gives you
those characters you can root for and
then and then pulls them in interesting
directions does anybody want to see a
clip from the movie before we run the
clip I just want to say okay yes is
because this is Hall H and some of you
probably brought your kids with us which
which by the way we should not be on the
hook for your bad parenting let's see
this nasty film but this is like the
edited for TV version so it has 100
percent less swinging dick then it would
if you saw it in the movies that sounds
like a joke kind of happy but no it's
actually a hundred percent serious so
there is there is imagine it for
yourself yeah
there is a dip moment and you know Alex
and Alex was like why can't we show the
dick moment it's just a little bit which
is kind of not cool to the actor in
question you know yeah but so so there
is like so you won't notice it no one
will notice it but there is like kind of
like you know we've cleaned it up we've
cleaned it up a little bit still a fun
game though yeah you you guys saw a
little bit of it with the with the news
reporters even the crap out anyway let's
take a look at a scene from Hortons I
don't think he had such a cool jacket
no maybe yeah I hope they let you keep
it after they after the thing was done
yeah how about the car the car is
exactly the same and there's a lot of
there's a lot of devil jokes in the book
like I kind of tried not to miss any of
them so it drives a gremlin because I
couldn't see him driving anything else
and that's a that's a pretty great car
and I got to sit in it and I was yeah
that was ugly awesome and I I don't I
don't dry it but I got to drive for this
movie which was a lot of fun for anyone
who wasn't in the car with me but anyone
did you take driving lessons I took a
few yeah absolutely and then we like did
it on obviously closed off roads and
stuff but there was yeah I remember I
had to hit a mark in someone's front
lawn look out here mark in the car and I
almost took out their like their garden
ornaments a couple of times but sitting
just yeah it was it was pretty there was
also like an amazing moment when the
kind of moment that can only happen in
film where we had to do this shot where
it was a wide shot of me driving up
parking getting out can't walking over
to a police car but it was all in the
white so I had to drive up and get out
myself and and I have a snake around me
at the time like a 6-foot long Python
and and you can't drive with the snake
around your neck because it hangs onto
the handle but the steering wheel and
the gears they can all their stuff and I
guess in the way so this guy had to get
in the back of the car with me and hold
the snake and then let's put it over my
shoulders at the last minute and it just
at the last minute I said to I turned I
realized like I can't drive and he's you
know getting in a car with me I should
at least tell him I can't drive and I
was like just so you know Corey like I'm
I don't I don't have a license I've
never really driven the car before and
he was like it's okay I'm never having
snakes before
so it was just one of those kind of
glorious moments that I only get in
films I can't decide if he has like the
most amazing life for the most horrible
and he wasn't doing it what are the job
asks you to drive around with a snake
over your shoulders and then like
somebody I have a brilliant job the
snake the snake was fantastic that III
if you've if you've never had a sexpert
Python around you I recommend the
experience oh okay I'm still fascinated
by it we didn't learn to drive in the
gremlin you learn to drive in like on
like another car yeah it's dick stick
shift for automatic automatic I was only
done they did have seven gremlins cuz
they knew he was gonna be so and I did
actually record car on a low loader
which is very hard to do because like
you're essentially you're not driving at
us on the background of the car that's
taking you along and I accidentally said
don't turn the wheel whatever you do
just don't turn the wheel but you've got
mine like the driving so like I was
doing a bit of like accidental turning
and then suddenly I realized the tires
had gone like that and we were going
that way and they were just like
shuddering and yeah I felt pretty
embarrassed there must be rushes of that
somewhere of my reaction to that oh yeah
I smell a DVD extra um I'm gonna ask two
more questions that I'm gonna open it up
to you all so if anyone wants to start
lining up maybe you already have please
do it the microphones Alex I want to ask
you you guys film this in the Pacific
Northwest takes place in Washington
State what is it about the Pacific
Northwest that's so creepy completed
because we've had all of these kind of
creepy dramatic films have you ever been
there right there I have that stuff
happened to me there is something about
the nature I guess you know like when
you were I was reading the book I wanted
to find a way to create that great
bridge between that biblical imagery
that kind of Garden of Eden that kind of
forest that was so important in the book
and that very Kurt Cobain America that
can hyper real like grigorik Woodson
kind of vibe and mix that together the
kind of David Lynch meets Diana
rheumatism of the 19th century and and I
was like you know we've been to a few
places but you know going like a Pacific
Northwest was definitely the only places
that are that vibe that can
Twin Peaks kind of flavor did you know
that Portland Oregon has more strip
shops no more strip clubs and more donut
shops than any other city in America I
think that fact is significant Wow and
then Dan in the movie you've got like an
equal number of great fight scenes and
really intense love scenes
what was the scarier one to take on I
think the like the toughest scene in the
film desert there's a scene in the diner
where me and Juno you know it doesn't
give too much away about the movie to
say that we break up in the scene but
it's a huge kind of arc of the scene
because I start off going into that
scene you know thinking that I'm going
to propose and so it's you know it's a
massive thing that and we filmed it for
we filmed it for two days and at the end
of the first day I remember thinking
arkad we won't have much longer on this
this is good we're getting there and and
then because it's a five pacing of
dialogue Alex you know how to get a lot
of coverage for her and so we shot it
for two days and it you know it's it's a
tough scene but you really you know I
was incredibly grateful for Alex but
also for you know Gino temple who you
you really can't wish for a better
person to go through one of those scenes
with she's committed and fearless and
generous and and just it would like
wonderful person to work with
she's amazing yeah she said she can't be
here but she's working
I'm sure this of course oh I see a
question right here from the audience
hello hi my name is Joel I just want to
say kill your darlings was amazing
that's me yes thank you thank you that's
I think that's everyone who saw it thank
you that I'm proud to be that one I
loved it um coming from you who's a
really diverse and phenomenal actor what
did you have to do to become this
rebellious now demonic American comes
into British culture like what it would
inspired you um I think you know I mean
I listen to one of the things I always
do with with films films anyway but
particularly with this film because
there was a lot of music referencing the
script and Alex and I you know we're
both very talked about music a lot and
so I made a like a playlist that was
kind of you know there was lots of
Metallica and Megadeth and yeah
and and what else do we what else we'll
be listening to you said Radiohead
earlier a lot of Radiohead yes and hope
of the states and and also like some
more sort of melancholic stuff like
perfume ingenious and kind of some bands
like that that just really kind of
turned the shippers who actually ended
up in the movie that's the first time I
ever got a song into a film by the way
that was read and yeah I mean though it
was really I broke down the character in
the same way that I've broken down every
character I played since since Potter in
terms of just establishing what it is
that they are trying to get and then out
of every scene what it is they want to
achieve out of that scene and then when
you say that line specifically what are
you trying to do to the person you were
saying that to so I break down all the
characters in the same way pretty much
and then you know just just I had had
some experience doing American accent on
stage and on killer darlings I'd also I
think being like growing up in Britain
there is you're so suffuse with American
culture that when I was a kid like I I
would give my action figures like
American accents and stuff so I've
secretly kind of been practicing this
since I was like six or seven thank you
my thanks for the question
I think he's being a little bit modest I
saw him in [ __ ] vanish Minh and it
sound it's he sounded like he grew up in
Dublin or Belfast you know and and that
that being able to do impersonations is
part of the gig and and he did so
flawlessly I I you know when I met him I
spent in a day with him and at the end
of the day I suddenly realized he had
been speaking an American the whole day
if there hadn't been any kind of trace
of an accent at all even when the
cameras weren't rolling so well I find
it it's easier when you do if you're
doing an accent to do it all the time
because then you don't all the little
things that you trip up on kind of get
ironed out by something if you're doing
it was all time and I love working in
accents as well just cuz it you know it
distances you know it makes me
I feel less recognizable when I watch
myself and that's always a pleasant but
it's like a character we're supposed to
identify with and kind of empathize with
or is he just kind of the best
manifestation of like all the negative
negative side of it no he's absolutely
somebody you should empathize with and
identify with he's somebody that's going
through an incredibly torrid time in his
life and
and is trying to keep what humanity has
being taken away from him by the
situation around him so I mean he's
definitely you know he's kind of a true
antihero in the I mean maybe you could
speak to this more than me Joe but but
in the sense that he he does things
throughout the movie that yeah you
should absolutely find questionable and
go or wonder what is happening to this
character that I like but you should I
think you know the attention if I've
done my job is that you're always kind
of with him
yeah it's physically he's turning into
the devil but he stay himself and it's
the world around that turns into hell
and just from a human point of view he's
mourning the loss of the love of his
life but also at the same time dealing
with the fact that everyone around him
thinks that he's responsible yeah so
it's grief and anger at the seams even
before he turns into a devil he's
already been demonized in his small town
where everyone thinks he's guilty for
this of this terrible crime it over the
course the movie inherits all the powers
of the devil chief among them he finds
out everybody's dark secrets they feel
compelled to confess to them their
darkest urges and they ask permission to
do even worse
and what animated the book and I think
what animates the film is a kind of
curiosity you know what would it do to a
person to see the worst and everyone you
love in all the people you're close to
what would happen you emotionally would
have destroy you
and I think what you see over the course
of the film and and the course of the
book is that even when faced with the
worst in the people you love it's still
possible to care about them and and
maybe even and maybe even love them you
know because of their fault it's not not
spite of them hello and I was just
wondering how the transition has been
for you as an actor moving from being
the Boy Who Lived to starring on
Broadway so now being a movie is this
such as Florence Thank You um it's been
fantastic you know I won't lie towards
the end of the the time on Potter I did
start to get a little worried I wasn't
before but then journalists started
coming up to me and saying things like
do you think your best years are behind
you
20 and so you know so that does get in
your head a little bit and you go I
don't want that to happen but I was
always very determined you know from the
time that I chose to do Equus between
numbers I guess it would been five and
six that you know I would I would have a
career after Potter and I think if you
you know Equus was a big thing for me it
was a frame doesn't know that was a
player did in London in New York and
it's it's very you know it's a
challenging dark play and I think that
sent a signal of intent to people that I
do want to challenge myself and do you
know and and you know broaden my
horizons as an actor and yeah I mean I
think if you if you take those
opportunities when they're given to you
and then take opportunities like a
chance to play Allen Ginsberg or or or
egg with Alex or you know whatever they
may be and try and capitalize on them
and then hopefully word gets out that
you you know no you're not content to
rest on your laurels you want to do one
of things I mean we're very is gonna see
horns I'm gonna realize that what
Daniels is doing in the movie shows that
you know Porter was only the beginning
of something great mm thank you
next question hello my name is Amanda
and I'm a huge fan and I just wanted to
say to Daniel that I love you and Harry
Potter has thank you meant so much to me
and I know it's meant so much to
thousands and thousands of people
everywhere so thank you you're very
welcome thank you very much I I really
you know I had a great time too you know
it was best thing I always say so it was
it was instrumental in a lot of people's
childhoods and I honestly never tire of
hearing that people come up to me all
the time would say thank you for you
know picking apart my childhood and
that's amazing thing to have like been
able to touch so many lives and and with
such you know films I'm really still
very very proud of particularly the
later ones I thought we did such a such
a good job on and yeah so it's it's a
pleasure to hear sorry thank you you're
welcome
my question is during the filming what
was either that your most favorite scene
or the hardest scene for you to film I
have there was one line in this film
which I was really looking forward to
saying
it there was a moment where it's it's
it's I can't really talk about this
without giving too much away something
terrible happens to me and then you know
and I should by all rights be dead and I
got to come out of the water and and be
surrounded by snakes and just say and
say god I'm really hard to kill with an
F word in there as well but I don't want
to say in case there's kids here but
like that was the moment that Alex just
came up to and Alex normally gives you
know very detailed and sort of you know
you know in-depth notes and stuff but on
that occasion he just came up to me and
said this you are Bruce Willis exactly
what you mean
so probably that but like honestly there
are a lot to choose from like the
fighting the game the journalist the
fight was awesome you know I took no
small pleasure out of that scene and and
you know that but a bunch like it yeah
every day it was just every day and
every day you came to set in knowing
that Alex was gonna have you doing
something amazing and creating something
visually that is just incredible to look
at so it was exciting every day to be a
part of it thank you
oh hello hello sir I promise this was a
crazy random happenstance ha ha ha ha I
just honestly wanted to ask you a
question ya know theater and uh um so
it's really I'm a theatre actor it's
really great to see you grow as an actor
I've kept up with your Broadway career I
you've really grown and it's it's great
to see you on Broadway and stuff but as
a theatre actor I'm curious what do you
like better theater or film I think you
know film is where I grew up and it's
where I was on a film set from you know
the age of 9 so I you know there is no
greater place of comfort and happiness
and just you know I feel so at home
there and that's what he gave me really
well like when I was taken out of school
I hated school I was not very good there
and I just I I was desperate to get out
of it and and so when I suddenly I found
this place on a film set where all the
things teachers hate about me at school
I was hyperactive and talkative and all
that we were you know welcomed on a film
set as being assets and and so I sort of
remember thinking god yeah I want to I
want to do this so I yet although I
think is somewhere that I
and I get better and I would recommend
it to every actor you know who has a
chance to do it should because it's it's
a different set of disciplines and a
different challenge doing something
night after night telling the whole
story in one night but it's um it's
something that I think I've learned a
lot from and hopefully we'll get to go
back to but but gun to my head I'd
choose film I have a question for the
sign language interpreter have you ever
interpreted someone who speaks this
quickly in your life yes thank you
um is good I'm very impressed okay next
question right here hi I'm Deanna um mr.
grant cliff you were not a part of my
childhood child when I was an adult but
I do have to say that I appreciate your
body of work I know that there are a lot
of child actors who come up and their
body of work diminishes as they get even
to your age of 25 happy birthday thank
you and I'm wondering if the expansion
of media opportunities has been and this
could be for the entire panel if the
expansion of media opportunities has
assisted child actors who take their
career seriously in expanding and
finding quality work to do that's an
amazingly astute question that I've
never been asked before so you just
achieved something that happens very
rarely um I I think you could be doing a
reality show right now like snorted
recreational coca seconds and you know
and and and the thing that I think I I
think that the the thing that I saw when
I went to crippled management and the
thing that I see in in warns is is a
level of crap that only comes when
you're working as hard or harder than
everyone else around you and you know I
think that's what makes a long career is
getting off on the craft yeah getting
off on the job you know having finding
new ways to have fun pressing yourself
to try things you've never tried before
and always wanting to be better and you
know he was talking about the scene he
does with with Jono temple and in this
scene with Juno Temple you have two
people who fiercely love each other
saying terrible things to each other and
hurting each other and hurting each
other you can't you just like ah every
I've seen the scene like 30 times now
and I still get goosebumps when I watch
it and I think that's about intensity
and craft and really you know getting
sort of dumping your ego and and just
working hard and you know oh that's what
makes a long career I think I mean I
read a line in a William Goldwyn book
when I was about 13 and so I was you
know I was I've been doing Potter and I
was so aware of it and and I their line
was something I'm paraphrasing there was
something along the lines of all stars
are temporary only actors last and I
remember thinking you know I want to
last like I want to be an actor and I
want to I actually think what you talked
about about media opportunities is
really smart because if you think about
you know when the first the Star Wars
films came out or when the you know
those those movies came out there wasn't
there were so many less opportunities
for you to be seen by the public as
yourself in terms of like than the
amount of press we do now so I do think
there was something in like the people
sort of getting I mean I have I've got
actually like the part I got in a film
called what-if which is coming out which
is like a romantic comedy I actually got
that actually kind of based on based on
doing extras with Ricky Gervais and
based on doing like the interviews that
the director had seen me and he thought
I would do it was a good fit for the
part so you know I do think that that
has sort of created opportunities thank
you for the question
hello hi I have a question for Danielle
you talked about what the differences
are in your preparation process for a
theatre versus film versus movies with
lots of sequels
I mean difference between theatre and
film is is again it's sort of in the way
I talked about breaking down characters
earlier it's very similar for both the
only thing different is that you that
you know you have to learn all your
lines well in advance rather than just
doing them sort of the day or the
weekend before so that's that's my main
paranoia before I go into a play is I
live in
constant fear of forgetting lines and
dropping that and being onstage sort of
stranded so you know that's one of the
things I focus on really hard also the
sort of the vocal preparation you don't
have to it's not something I do now so
much because I've done you know I have a
basis in it now but the before when I
when I first hit at course I did like 18
months of kind of vocal preparation just
learning how to project and stuff before
I go into rehearsals because it is a so
different animal thank you thank you
hello hi I was just I have a question
for Daniel on her head hair and Jo so
you had mentioned that Daniel found the
role and came to you and I was wondering
how do you find roles especially with
such a big you know Potter over your
head and then for Jo were you nervous
when he was attached to the project and
did you think it would kind of change
your story which is brilliant by the way
I mean uh it's bit I get parts Jenny
I've got you know fantastic agents who
are very good at you know knowing they
know the kind of career I want to have
and they know the kind of movies I want
to do and so they look for those movies
and when they found this script and sent
it to me it was something as Alex said I
became totally obsessed with and you
know I don't as I said you know there
may have been there and there may be and
I'm sure there still are a lot of people
who just see me as Harry and and just
want to but but also you know it only
takes one director to not so give you an
opportunity to prove that you're
something else you know and and luckily
so far I've had you know four or five
directors that have all you know taking
a chance on me and wanted to see me
doing something different so um
hopefully it won't cost you big of a
shadow over it enjoy your first reaction
to the news I I just felt I mean blown
away just completely amazed it yeah I
was like did you sure he read it
no I you know tremendously tremendously
lucky and and tremendously excited and
you know I mean I'm a Harry Potter fan
too I saw all those movies over and over
and have read those books over and over
and and and I think you know it's a it's
not just Dan it's it's a lot of the
actors who worked in Harry Potter that
must have been that was like the world's
greatest acting school you know it's
just amazing all these incredible you
know Alan Rickman and all these in you
know whatever through this amazing
amazing actors to to work and teach with
and to be constantly around them what an
experience has never been anything like
it
I don't think it's any surprise that all
these guys have gone on to do impressive
exciting work they all work very hard
and learned a lot and and it makes sense
to me and we had a really good time I
mean that's I think it's telling that
we've all continued in our careers
because we you know I think you hear
about a lot of people having a not a
good time and actually I believe that
the film industry is was the making of
me and and has made us responsible for
the person I am and I'm very grateful to
it you know it's a great place to go up
I'm totally have time for one last
question so sir it's yours yeah I have a
question for Jo is there another work of
yours that you'd like to adapt to
perhaps something that we can be looking
forward to I I do have a I do have a
comic book that I made with my great
friend Gabriel Rodriguez called lock and
key and lock and key was filmed as a TV
show for Fox they filmed the pilot and
it was great it was amazing and the show
is now in its third hit season in my
imagination in in real life Fox decided
not to air it and so we were sort of
left left you know we came up empty
which sometimes those are the breaks
but but now it's in development a
universal they'd like to do it as a
trilogy of films and and my
understanding is they have a pretty good
script for the first one but I haven't
read it yet so you know
fingers crossed but but you know I'm
proud of the comic and and the comic
will be what it is whether there's a
film or not dan I just want to know how
did your first haul each experience
measure up to what you hope for
unexpected it was fantastic I have many
memories particularly happy birthday so
thank you very much for that guys
you